investors.com Dow Jones drops on hot
inflation data so we're down what uh or
down again several percentage points
what's going on the Market's imploding
we're seeing real estate prices drop
we're seeing inflation across the board
I think food prices are up in Germany
what like night was it 19 or something
or
yeah I don't know something like that
double digits oh it's going to be bad
um so well so uh aside from the
potassium iodide what kind of emergency
food have you got about
I cook with a lot of lentils I'm it's
like Ian's cooking lentils every day red
lentils baby this is why it's actually
nice to be in America you know like we
have a lot of food in this country we
don't need to import it we're not in the
position of a lot of countries that do
um you know we we really are blessed by
our Geographic advantages in so many
different ways oh yeah you know oceans
on two sides of us substantially you
know smaller countries on the North and
South good neighbors good neighbors uh
incredible waterways I think somebody
somebody did a map once where they
described the navigable waterways of of
the United States huge mountains that of
course are very difficult to Traverse
sure amazing but you know yeah I mean so
and you can build stuff in them like
underground bases that's right well that
can withstand nuclear I'm just saying
there's there's so much natural Farmland
in the United States it just dwarfs
almost anywhere else in the world in
terms of just the amount on a Farmland
and be available yeah a lot of country
to produce its own food yeah and uh we
don't we don't have to buy cat food
actually because bocus just caught a
squirrel the other day and we couldn't
again no I just thought I'm talking
about the one that he got and he he went
into one of the ramps we couldn't get
him out and I guess he just ate it so
you know well there's that that's cheap
when you live out here in the middle of
nowhere man you can uh you can grow your
own food it's pawpaw season guys you
know we we had a paw paw bread today it
was amazing oh good Papa's hillbilly
banana
so uh there's food aplenty but if you
live in a big city like New York or even
outside of one like I don't know
Arlington for instance you're probably
in trouble especially with the potential
attacks on infrastructure so if energy
goes out if the internet goes out which
again a lot of it is dependent on
underground cables which I think we
should be keeping a close eye on because
I do believe there's supposed to be some
significance that can be that's a
logical way for Russia to retaliate
against us that's very logical you're
going to be watching your house of
dragons and it's going to cut off yeah
and then it's going to be like we can't
load because Russia cut a cable
come on
or you can't have an energy I mean if
you can't have energy or Communications
in a place like New York City I mean
you're screwed people people don't
understand how how spoiled we've gotten
I want you to imagine this scenario
you're sitting in your house when all of
a sudden the power goes out
cell lines are down your phone doesn't
work you can't text anybody you have no
internet it's just you and your family
you live let's say you live in a small
suburban community
all of a sudden you know it's a couple
hours you're talking to neighbors like
what's going on we don't know military
vehicles pull up
next time you're lucky they tell you get
everybody line up line up what do you do
you have no idea who they are you have
no idea what's going on do you just say
yes what if it's the enemy what if
something serious what if they took out
a substation what if they've invaded
what do you do well I would say if the
military shows up in a situation that
comply because it's probably the good
guys if they show up right away
um
look at them if they have American
insignias on them don't fight them
they're probably there to help it's
probably a National Guard coming out if
something really bad happens but you
know obviously don't just learned
nothing when the men just don't don't
don't you know don't think Don't Go full
paranoia Insane Mode right away if
something bad happens you know keep your
wits about you and remember that we're
on American soil we're all here together
when your power and Communications go
down and a military vehicle pulls up no
don't comply demand confirmation yeah
but I mean
basically is what I'm saying like like
just be leave and then let be uh you
know you don't have to comply you don't
have to go along with with whatever
military you might show up at your door
want you to do is it an assessment of
like what the odds are whether they're
friendly or enemy military yeah I mean
obviously the odds are it's a friendly
military
or if there's like a coup d'etat exactly
but that'll be in DC right yeah but that
will happen it's not even about that
it's about they've rounded Americans up
before and put them in camps right in
World War II this happened but even even
I mean don't just say sure I'll get on
the bus well but like should should the
Japanese have you know violently
resisted the efforts of that have been
smart for the Japanese it could be
peacefully and passively resisted at the
very least I don't know I just I think
it you know it's one of those like
horrible things but the outcomes for the
Japanese people who resisted would not
have been better than those who that
complied like it's an appalling a human
rights abuse by our government but that
doesn't mean that like the correct and
practical course of action for the
victims of that oppression was to
violently I'm not sure at the same time
the appropriate response is to willfully
enter a concentration camp no no don't
just jump into the fire when you see it
burning but you know use discretion and
don't just assume it's the enemy of
something you don't have to resist you
don't have to comply either but but you
know you could you could force the issue
and make it more of a debate yeah sure
you could definitely make it like some
sort of like civil decision
we're talking about overt violations of
the Constitution like and civil rights
and humans criminal actions being placed
being made against the American citizens
because they were scared at some of them
because of the way they looked may have
been spots in hindsight if you were
Japanese during World War II what would
you do
I don't know that's a like it I'm trying
to I think that I would try and avoid
detection by the guy well right I would
try and avoid it I wouldn't I don't
think I'd like start shooting at
government agents to yeah avoid being
taken to a to one of the camps but I
think I would try and like of you know
I'd try and avoid them Hide You Wanna of
course try to go through everything
before resorting to violence uh you want
to try all options
Disobedience protesting but like it's a
difficult question what should the Jews
in Germany have done
uh different I mean different given that
the I mean and I think the Warsaw
Uprising demonstrates this right like
the way that in it was a there is a
category difference between how we
treated the Japanese people and how the
Nazis treated Jews right yeah genus you
know the camps versus genocide is a big
big goal a lot of a lot of the the the
Jewish people and it wasn't just Jewish
people it was it was Polish people it
was gay people a lot of these
handicapped people a lot of gypsies they
weren't beaten and dragged into some
into these train carts many of them were
just they pulled up and said all right
you know we're getting in we're bringing
you to a camp well a lot of them were
also work camps like my family got sent
to a work camp and then they had death
camps as well so uh my my
great-grandmother was in a war camp with
my grandmother my grandmother tells me
the stories and and the craziness of
that situation and uh you know she was
extremely lucky and randomly a a family
just decided to pick her up after her
her mother my great-grandmother was sent
off to death camp and she died there and
uh a family adopted my grandmother and
that's the only reason she she survived
that's the only reason I'm here today
they went to a work camp and picked her
up in Poland when the German government
took over during World War II if you had
a number of kids you didn't have to pay
taxes
um and and the state liked that you had
a number of kids because you were
procreating so there was a family that
didn't have enough kids to not pay taxes
didn't have enough kids to to get the
government benefits so they adopted one
off of one of the trains that was
heading off to the stuttoff camp and
that's where you know my
great-grandmother passed away so in
hindsight you know I mean it's something
people should consider Luke was born in
a Soviet satellite yeah I was like this
stuff my family took part in the in the
salad protest that of course was a big
part of taking down communism a big part
of taking down the Soviet Union so now
people know where he gets it from well
yeah absolutely you know you're raised
in this stuff and you have your family
tell you hey this happened to your uncle
this is the torture that he went through
hey this is the the secret jail the
secret you know this is the craziness
that we faced this here then and then
and then and you keep hearing these
stories and it's just absolutely
um you know it it it it it it builds who
you are because it teaches you the
important lessons of history that sadly
a lot of people have forgotten and this
is why I'm so passionate about these
issues this is why I've been at this for
so long because the writing is on the
wall and I think it's only a matter of
time until we we repeat history and I
think in many instances we already have
you mentioned Communications being part
of uh the danger of loss of electricity
all that in New York or whatever but
like so would it be wise for people then
to get CB radios with like a solar solar
charger or something it would probably
get that for 100 bucks a regular AM FM
radio yeah 28 bucks hand crank you ever
see those you you can crank it to charge
the battery yeah yeah get one of those
exhausting you charge for a while but it
works but you you want to hear what's
going on because they may say you'll
turn the radio on and it'll say A large
group of whatever are heading down
heading south down I-90 as leave the
area now you you know it's estimated
they'll arrive within one hour and then
you're gonna be like okay it's time to
get out of here yeah two-way radio too
that's that'll if the internet goes yeah
that's the kind of stuff that's
happening in Ukraine I'm sure yeah like
or happened especially during uh Jimmy
advances I I mean people just don't get
it all right imagine you're in your
neighborhood imagine there's shooting
going on in every direction
you walk outside
it's cold do you wear a coat yes or no
yeah you get shot oh right because
someone sees you they don't know what
you're carrying they say don't know
don't care I'm not taking the risk when
there's active conflict going on this
this so This is actually what's
something that happened to guy I think
was like a civilian was walking down the
street someone shot him because they
were like the coat was big they couldn't
tell if he was armed or not and they
didn't want to take a risk because
there's Russian and Ukrainian forces
fighting you see a random guy you say
you want to risk it you want to be the
one to walk over them and make sure that
he's on your side or not or would you
rather just sweep the area with your
team you know you can trust and say
screw it to everybody else people don't
get what war is like I'm not going to
pretend to have been in it I've been in
civil unrest and and some civil conflict
and even then it's crazy the craziest
thing about it is how normal things
continue this is what really bugs me
about the whole Civil War narrative
when uh Scott Adams and and you know uh
Bill Burr were like go outside nobody's
fighting Scott Adams said there's not
going to be a civil war you know how I
know right and then and then he said
there's there's no there's no appetite
for outside of Twitter's imagination and
someone responded how do you know he
said what's your Source he said I went
outside yes I've I've been uh I was in
Kiev during the euromaidan protests
there were riots there were police it
was getting crazy they were tense and
then you walk two blocks and you're at a
shopping center in fact the shopping
center was in the maidan Square so like
you could walk from the protests where
there had been people firebombing tanks
or apcs and you could walk inside and
I'm gonna buy uh I'm gonna buy this coat
right here in this this shopping in
Egypt during the revolution you could
walk two blocks from Tahira square and
there's a McDonald's with people eating
cheeseburgers and they're watching the
game in the Hilton Hotel
you could walk in while people this is
the craziest thing I'm on the 26th floor
looking down people are throwing things
at each other they're shooting each
other it was too warning it was it was
two rival factions secular group and the
Muslim Brotherhood apcs start rolling
through with people riding on top
they're hooting and hollering I walk 10
feet and there's a casino people are
playing games and acting like nothing is
happening people seem to think that when
War breaks out it's everyone running
around flailing throwing things and
screaming people still have to live
stores try to operate sometimes it gets
so bad that the bullets stop people from
doing it but if you've if you know you
look at these videos out of Syria
and there are people walking down the
street carrying like a basket full of
fruits while there's like shelling going
on what are they supposed to do they got
to eat humans still have to do these
things the best the craziest thing when
the war in Syria broke out we tried
pursuing the story while advice the
Damascus tourism board was advertising
for people even in the United States to
come party and enjoy the nightlife of
Damascus when they were like fears of
sarin gas attacks and so we were like we
were advice and we're like can we do
this like can we go to Damascus and film
a video that's literally just us
partying and entertaining what they're
what they're advertising while
acknowledging this war is going on so
you're saying you don't shut down for
war but maybe for a virus sometimes I
don't get it what's worse here uh you
know shout out to Elon Musk and starlink
and anyone else that's working on
satellite internet because of our
terrestrial internet does go down which
is sounds extremely vulnerable if it's
underwater and cables right along where
those pipelines run they just got one of
those just we need you know a backup and
if we got internet satellite lights then
at least we'll be able to keep talking
to each other I think that we can
maintain order in a blackout there's a
satellite Communications two-way texting
devices they're only a couple hundred
bucks
I recommend it yeah satellite internet's
getting a lot better that's why that's
why WI-Fi is a lot better on planes the
new iPhones have satellite uh as well
yep the new iPhones if you get lost and
there's no cell phone service you could
literally use the iPhone as a way to
track down satellites as a way to send
out an SOS signal and reach search and
rescue anywhere and everywhere
yes SOS via satellite yeah that's
impressive yeah so I mean yeah so 10
years ago I was doing a buddy of mine
was doing security Consulting I was
assisting him he was a security guy I
wasn't but you know I know a little bit
about infosec stuff and Tack and drones
but one of the things that he got was a
two-way texting device that allows you
to send text messages it's this little
gray box I'd have to imagine 10 years
later the technology is vastly improved
so that's really cool and now it's in
your cell phone the new iPhone 14 well
he's got one great yeah it's not even
the phone it's in it's in the software
update right like I think my phone which
is a 13. I remember seeing that I'm not
an SOS sure because it's a new antenna
that they're using to link with the
satellite it might you might be right
but I don't I'm not done I don't know my
phone suggest I think my phone suggests
it because like when I'm out when I have
no bars I see SOS and I'm like that
takes over a minute to send under trees
with light or medium footage that's
crazy if you're in ideal conditions you
have a view of the sky and the Horizon
it'll take 15 seconds to send oh my gosh
it's just an SOS call you don't get to
send tech can you send text well you
send information about what's going on
here and you go through the prompts
especially 14. okay yeah it says well it
it is coming with an update but it says
using emergency SOS via your iPhone okay
here I guess you have to you have to
have an iPhone 14. yeah wow I actually
want to get one now I mean imagine
you're hiking and you get lost yeah
that's really that's just hold it up and
just wait for a minute and then they're
gonna get a GPS coordinate then you just
bunker down right wow yep
cool stuff modern technology that's
awesome yeah it can be used to track you
everywhere you go probably they're
probably completely probably a back door
in there that of course it's like
satellites we can't see what he's saying
sending the satellites but it gives you
the chance to track yourself which is
pretty cool yeah I do they gotta this
software should be free for sure because
now there's no escaping the the the
DARPA dark net and the surveillance
system well the worrying thing is that
technology has eventually become
Necessities luxuries become Necessities
so what happens is in 20 years you're
walking through a forest there's a you
know a guy drive you know Park a Park
employee or a park ranger pulls up and
he goes you didn't register on the uh
Beacon system where's your uh where's
your GPS it's like I don't have one
put your hands behind your back but I'm
from 2021 let me go where's your
permission slip to be in nature which is
what they're doing more and more
efficiently you literally need
permission slip to go into a lot of
national parks and you need to make
reservations sometimes years in advance
it's absolutely crazy that the
government is limiting people's ability
to be in nature and that's just
um I want to use some French language
here but I won't uh absolutely wrong
that's one of the criminal French when
people start swearing up a storm they're
like that's French man I love them
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there